chair you want by the way you should
look and see which one I want I think
Helen said witches hi everybody Dame
Helen said which is my chair I said
whichever chair you want it's true I we
were in in Sicily together this summer
we were I I was kind of escorting Drew
down the red carpet
um it was a sicilian it was Dolce
gabbana's show and it was the men's show
and Drew decided to come dressed as a
man yes and she looked fantastic I'm
absolutely amazing you had little
freckles on your face I remember that
yeah and I I don't think people knew it
was me you did because you get it yeah
but um it was so exciting to be um Dame
Helen adjacent in fact I ran and I uh
photo bombed the photo you were taking
with Mariah Carey
um and Sharon Stone oh my god seriously
with them yes I really went by in a blur
for me it was like so exciting I could
sort of hardly deal with it really it's
so exciting to see these huge stars like
Mariah Carey or Sharon Stone isn't it I
mean we get intimidated as much as
anybody else I do anyway I don't know
about you you I get so excited to see
them and sort of intimidating and and
like I was like pinching myself thinking
oh my God I'm sitting here with Mariah
Carey and Sharon Stone this is amazing
you know you get um I get terribly over
excited I do too I'm gonna get terribly
over excited that's a real issue with me
I once met Clint Eastwood and I was like
oh my God
and he just looked at me when
and I was like oh my God that's so Clint
Eastwood up you I'll just leave that was
his way of saying I love you back drew
that was just that was just his version
of being excited I I just have never
been able to play it cool but also I'm
just so happy to hear from you know
someone of your stature that you feel
that way because that's exactly how I
feel like I will never be jaded I will
never not be
struck I will never not Marvel in
someone's body of work and
accomplishments like and be excited to
be where we are I mean it's it's such a
it's such a wonderful thing and and it's
not necessarily you know these beautiful
functions like the Dolce Cabana
situation but um I think just watching
other people work and appreciating it
and and being impressed by it and
sometimes overwhelmed by it
um I mean my goodness Drew you've been
in the business you know as we call the
business you know for for ever since
you're a very small girl diapers you
know you have diapers yes exactly so um
you know you have every reason to be
sort of a little blase about the whole
thing but it's so great that you're not
um I just I just love great talent and
and I feel
um so
um humbled but that's not quite the
right word but you know I I just
um I'm impressed by great talent and and
and and when you find yourself in the
presence of great talent
um I I always feel very
um uh what's the word not as good as
them I can't think of the right word
like there's a little bit of you know
because I don't feel like I'm an
inferior or an insecure person per se
but I I don't remember any of my
accomplishments in those moments when
I'm around other people that I admire
yeah yeah is that it I think that is it
I think it is oh it's just the pleasure
of of of recognizing you know great
ability uh you know in Shazam we worked
with Rachel Ziegler and the great Lucy
Liu of course as well but
extraordinarily
you know extraordinary talented women
and and to be in the Pres the presence
of both of them was humbling for me you
know
um Rachel who has is a wonderful actress
in the prettiest thing incidentally
West Side Story Steven Spielberg's yeah
imagining and she took that mantle and
just lifted it up yes she's also the new
um uh Snow White and and she's in the
film I did with her called Shazam well
she has this
she has this voice she has she's
beautiful she's a wonderful actress and
she can sing like an angel I mean she
has the most she's a tiny little thing
and this big beautiful voice comes out
of her she wouldn't do it she would sing
quietly to herself so you'd have to sort
of side look behind her sort of listen
in quietly because if she saw you
listening she'd stop you know but to be
in the presence of talent like that I
just find so exciting Lucy was here and
she said that you gave them all a a
nickname a mantra a um a moniker if you
did yes because superheroes will you
know there are a few females you would
be super heroines but they're mostly men
so when we walked out onto the set for
the first time in our costumes and
everything I said okay everybody power
is here
laughs
so
[Music]
um and um and and the girls on the set
absolutely loved it they cracked up they
thought it was the funniest thing so the
um the girls on the production side
they're on the set design set building
side made this beautiful little
embroidered
um just very like very sweet very
feminine with little flowers and
everything and embroidered onto that
said
power
and I have to say I have a present for
you and it was snuck onto the set
without you knowing and here it is
[Applause]
n't that the coolest thing
um I am so excited to be anointed in a
daytime television
thank you for welcoming you
deserve it to the nth degree Drew you
have it you have it to the map darling
you have it to the max I'm just so
excited to be with you I've been looking
forward to this so much I mean your Dame
Helen Mirren you have you have really
you know changed the world with your
body of work and your grace and your
talent and the woman that you are I mean
oh my gosh you are you in fact with that
do you mind if I play my favorite game
with you no behind
[Applause]
thing I mean
oh let's kick it back to I was losing
gas I remember seeing this kid as a kid
and being like this
movie is so incredible it was so racy
and unique and I'm sitting here having
my cup of tea yes exactly exactly with
the crochet yes exactly I mean Caligula
made a huge like I mean people people
would not stop talking about it it did
at the time it was a very shocking thing
actually they're doing a re a re-cut of
it a re-edit of it really Tinto Brass
the um original filmmaker was very very
brilliant wild radical sort of Italian
filmmaker and then um Bob guccione who
was the Penthouse Magazine guy who was
financing it yeah came in and reading
came in and um and added scenes that
were you know not they were so soft porn
scenes really and and not very
interesting and sort of destroyed the
movie
um but at the heart of it it you know it
was about ancient Rome for God's sake
you know I mean
my for goodness sake I should say
um so um you know it was it was pretty
out there but it was an amazing
extraordinary experience I have to say
it really it was a big big deal okay the
mosquito Coast with Harrison Ford
oh gosh I was quite young man I wasn't
that young actually but I look so young
what are you thinking when you look at
Harrison Ford